what's popping Marvels it's me Mt and
welcome back to the heavy spoiler show
this is going to be an ending explained
for the reality smashing Sisterhood of
the Traveling superheroes that is the
Marvel so sit back grab your
Intergalactic cat and let us bite into
this action packed snack of a Marvel
film spoiler warning for everything in
the marvels of course so if you have not
seen that movie give this video a pause
and then come back when you're done son
all right so let's start this video off
by talking about that super exciting mid
credit scene that features a Monica
Rambo waking up in the medical Bay of
the X-Men's underground headquarters
designed extremely similarly to the way
it was in the original X-Men films from
the early 2000s Monica awakens to the
sight of a woman that she thinks is her
mother but is actually a Maria Rambo
variant codenamed binary a name that
should sound very familiar to Captain
Marvel comic fans in the comics binary
was originally one of the names Carol
Danvers gave herself after after she
gained the cosmic powers of a white hole
in X-Men 164 following genetic
experimentation by the alien race called
The Brood really creepy guys which
triggered Carol's latent mutant
potential giving her the ability to
generate radiation and heat as hot as
the brightest star and to produce light
on any wave of the electromagnetic
spectrum when this happened to Carol in
the comics she was pretty much offered a
spot on the X-Men immediately but she
refused to join the team due to not
wanting to be tied down on Earth since
binary was introduced as a genetic
mutation in the comics it seems like
this Maria Rambo's binary took the X-Men
up on their offer in her universe and
has now become the newest mutant on the
MCU scene just like Camala was revealed
to be in the season finale of Miss
Marvel so there is definitely something
about the human body coming into contact
with Cosmic radiation that triggers
mutation much like Professor Xavier says
in the pages of X-Men number 12 and like
Patrick Stewart Xavier tells the X-Men
in the first X-Men movie in regards to
Magneto's evolving machine the machine
emits radiation that triggers mutation
in an ordinary human being but anyways
Maria's costume has two stars on the
chest region to represent a binary star
system which is basically what happens
when a star orbits around or close to
another star in space however though
Maria Rambo is binary in this universe
apparently there was a 50% chance that
binary could have been another variant
of Carol Danver as we learned in the
Marvels that Maria and Carol had a foot
race to the plane that would inevitably
crash and give the winner of that foot
race the cosmic powers of Captain Marvel
so in every Universe where Maria Rambo
has superpowers it is implied that Maria
was the one who beat Carol in that foot
race to Marvel's plane Kelsey Grammar of
course reprises his role as the mutant
Beast after playing the iconic character
in both X-Men the Last Stand as well as
X-Men Days of Future Past however this
version of Beast is a lot different
different in presentation than the one
that we've seen from the fox movies as
Marvel Studios has chosen to go with a
slightly different full CG model of
beast in this universe making me feel
like this universe is a completely new
universe that is meant to be a variant
of Earth 838 from Multiverse of manness
since Maria Rambo Captain Marvel had a
close relationship with Professor Xavier
on Earth 838 as a member of the
Illuminati it seems like this new Maria
Rambo binary variant is a member of
Xavier's X-Men outright in this universe
due to to her mutation however there is
a chance that this universe could be the
same one that Logan wakes up in at the
End of Days of Future Past as music from
the Days of Future Past score plays
during the Marvel's mid credit scene and
we do know that Professor Xavier is
Alive and Well in this universe thanks
to Beast mentioning that Xavier was
requesting an update from binary about
Monica's condition so there's a big
chance here that Monica Rambo's arrival
and the oncoming threat of incursions
could be part of Professor Xavier's
information download that he promised to
give Wolverine at the end of his time
traveling adventure in Days of Future
Past Deadpool 3 for sure seems like the
MCU project that we will likely see
Monica continue her X-Men adventures in
next as that movie is rumored to be
extremely Multiverse Centric with a
bunch of returning Fox X-Men Stars
however there is also a chance that the
next season of what if or the new X-Men
97 series could also continue Monica and
Maria's mutant narrative as well part of
me really hopes that Marvel is secretly
planning and Avengers versus X-men
scenario on the road to Secret Wars
because with the multiversal incursions
on the horizon it is quite possible that
these two teams will have to fight for
their respective realities to survive
much like Sinister strange had to do
with his nightmare reality using the
darkh hold my boy Paul has a really Dope
video about an Avengers versus X-men
scenario that you guys should check out
as soon as it's out because he's got
some really fun ideas there but speaking
of incursions now let us talk about
arguably the most important event of
this movie movie which is of course our
newest sighting of a multiversal
incursion in the MCU 616 reality as
first teased by John kosinski's Mr
Fantastic and Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness and is a direct
consequence of Sylvie sending the
Multiverse into chaos by choosing to
murder he who remains at the very end of
the first season of Loki we got our
first appetizer for what a post he who
remains Multiverse would look like in
Spider-Man no way home when the entire
616 reality almost Came Crashing Down
due to he who remains his multiversal
management going completely out the
window allowing for any and all
multiversal possibilities across time
and space to happen you know like
vulture being sent to morbius land 616
Aaron Davis being arrested by the spider
Society shuni being able to access the
alternate universe of talo Aisha and
najma being able to enter the 616
universe and so on and so forth and if
you don't already know multiversal
incursions are kind of a big deal in
both the MCU and the Marvel Comics in
general because they spelled the
beginning of the end of the entire
Marvel Multiverse what Mr Fantastic
warns Doctor Strange about in Multiverse
of Madness begins to happen in this
movie as darb Ben's power causes the
multiversal boundaries of the MCU 616
reality to crumble allowing for a
neighboring Universe to begin to
chaotically collide with their own when
those tears first begin to form in the
movie I noticed that the gravitational
disturbance that the portal causes was
very reminiscent to the nearly destroyed
V variant of Earth that doctor strange
and Christine Palmer got sent to by
Wanda in Doctor Strange 2 as the natural
gravitational laws of that Universe were
completely wrecked after suffering the
consequences of their own multiversal
incursion courtesy of the three-eyed
dark Sinister strange I have a feeling
that that same dark purple Power that
Darb's bangle emitted to cause the
incursion in the Marvel's movie is the
same type of dark purple cosmic power
that Sinister strange used to
destabilize his own reality the Marvel's
also features the brief Return of the
cre Supreme intelligence to the MCU but
this time in its true form a form that
is extremely Comics accurate because
instead of seeing the Supreme
intelligence manifested in the realm of
Carol's mind as the person her brain
admired the most we got to see the
Supreme intelligence's true form a big
ass green head with tentacles coming out
of it like the Marvel world first saw in
the pages of fantastic 465 much like in
the comics the Supreme intelligence is
of course the combined Collective
consciousnesses of all the loyal and
high value Cree that have lived and died
on the planet and because of this yon
rag refers to the Supreme intelligence
as the collective when he tells Carol
and the cre Star Force to possibly
prepare to join the collective should
they all die during their mission to the
vibranium Rich planet of torfa in the
first Captain Marvel movie so the
Supreme intelligence should definitely
be added to the list of MCU after lives
in my opinion but that's just me however
the most interesting thing to me about
the MCU Supreme intelligence is just how
much they follow the same Celestial
science established in the eternals
movie because in that movie we learn
that celestials are born from the
combined mind energy consciousnesses of
millions of dead people that have been
absorbed by arishem Celestial seed
placed within the core of the planet in
the same vein it seems that the cre have
managed to master that science of
collecting mind energy and have made
their own artificial Celestial being
using technology with the Supreme
intelligence even possessing Four Eyes
just like tiama does however Carol would
of course end up completely annihilating
all of those mind energies that comprise
the Supreme intelligence in a massive
blast of energy giving her the nickname
the annihilator amongst the cre and
creating a chaotic power vacuum but
while we're on the subject of the cre
power vacuum now let's talk about the
film's main villain zoi Ashton's darb
Ben when darb Ben was first announced as
the main villain for the Marvels people
were understandably confused as the
character of darban in the comics has
only appeared in 1991's Silver Surfer
number 53 3 and 1992's Avengers 346 in
the comics darb Ben was a cre War
General who usurped the cre Throne along
with his War General homie Al Den ending
the reign of the stupid ass cre leader
clumsy foul up after darb Ben and his
Dar friend killed clumsy foul up they
became co-emperors of the entire cre
Empire before they themselves were
killed by deathbird of the shiar Empire
differing from her comic book
counterpart greatly zi Ashton's darbin
chooses to rule extremely independently
rather than having a shared rulership
with another fellow Warrior this was of
course purposely done to serve as an
opposite to the teamwork that Carol
Kamala and Monica learned to have over
the course of the film that would of
course help them defeat darb Ben's
lonely ass self all darb Ben needed was
her fancy new bangle the missing bangle
that everyone was looking for in the
Miss Marvel series that we finally
learned to be the mcu's adaptation of
the quantum bands which in the Marvel
Comics has been historically the weapon
crafted for the protector of the
universe by The Cosmic deity Eon a
character that was officially made into
MCU Cannon through one of the statues
inside of the gates of eternity from
Thor love and Thunder with the most
popular of these chosen protectors
throughout history to be known as the
Marvel hero quazar a title that has
historically belonged to multiple Marvel
Comics characters including Wendel Von
phael and AAL concade but in the MCU
they've been given to Kamala KH first in
order for her to produce hardik
constructs into any shape that she
desires something that the quantum bands
has been also able to do for quazar in
the comics time and time again but while
quazar sourced his energy from a cosmic
Source called the quantum Zone MCU Miss
Marvel seemingly gets her powers by
using the latent cosmic energy inside of
her cosmic energy that also appears to
be the root of her mysterious mutant
Heritage the quantum bands are not to be
confused with the famous Nega band bands
that empowered the original Captain
Marvel from the comics and caused that
Captain Marvel to become entangled with
his human friend Rick Jones forcing them
to trade places periodically much like
we see the Marvel's do in the movie
however in their case while either
Captain Marvel or Rick was occupying
space in the normal Universe the other
one of them was forced to be trapped
inside of the negative zone until the
other one tapped them back into reality
less than ideal situation indeed but
anyways while the Nega bands in the
Quantum bands may seem like the same
thing the Nega bands were actually
created by the cre a long ass time ago
based off of the quantum bands anyways
finally before we wrap up this video
we've got to talk about the other post
credit scene that features the return of
the greatest Marvel actress of all time
Haley Steinfeld and all of her beautiful
face to Glory if you don't know me
already I'm a huge Haley Steinfeld simp
so you know get used to that like that
was literally the highlight of the movie
for me to the point where the whole
X-Men thing was was just a lucky bonus
anyways as you can probably guess Cala
recreating Marvel's first post-credit
scene of Nick Fury's iconic meeting with
Tony Stark at the end of Iron Man 1 was
for sure a tease for camalo founding a
new type of Avengers team for young
people that will almost certainly be the
Young Avengers which would be a first
for Camala as Miss Marvel in the comics
has historically not been on the Young
Avengers team in fact comic book Kate
Bishop was actually one of the original
members of the group alongside Elijah
Bradley's Patriot
Billy maximoff's Wiccan Teddy alman's
hulkling Cassie Lang's stature and an
iron lad that was secretly a young Kang
variant that wanted to defy his fate as
a bad guy it was actually iron land
himself who first founded the Young
Avengers in the comics so whether or not
iron lad will factor into the MCU Young
Avengers during this Kang Centric
Multiverse narrative has yet to be seen
but anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow Me @
m rainment on Twitter if you guys want
to see me post some really weird
but most importantly you can follow
spoilers here on YouTube or wherever we
are on the internet so you guys can keep
up to date with everything that we do
and again don't forget to like And
subscribe to the channel that really
does go a long way but yeah thanks again
for watching I love you guys so much and
I'll see you guys next time goodbye